Android is a fast-growing platform.
Updated sdk new design language development tools etc.
In order to improve and make life easier for developers,
To improve Android app functionality and make your ecosystem richer
We are making a lot of effort.
4 Of course, the world's work is a bit different from what happened in the world
There were occasions when
Hello, it's Developer Artworks for Ms. As always.
i5 has released a lot of new news about Android
For developers who have not been able to see the news because of their busy schedule
It's simple to see what developers are interested in, but what updates
I'm going to take a look.
Above all, the new Android platform misses out on Android caressing news
I can not.
In the m version, patterns are used to increase the stability of the platform,
Many improvements are being made to
At the same time, when a user launches an app,
Effective power management, including the authorization model,
New Autobackup to help you easily back up your app data
Service was also added
As always, upgrading will cause compatibility issues.
The same is true for the preview version of m.
You can see the various changes at a glance
A lot of developers have already released the developer preview
We're in the process of testing.
If you have not tested your app on m yet
Why do not you start testing?
Android t tried to release new version 1.3
In December, Android Studio 1.0 was officially released
Based on your feedback, we continue to add and enhance various features
There is
First you do not waste any more time with such xml files.
To make it easier for you to design your app, the theme editor and ui
Editor and improved
The cradle version is also updated to 2.4
There is also a lot of news from the developers
I do not know. Finally, version 1.3 includes ndk, c plus
Plus development environment will be supported
However, the first preview version still includes the feature
Please do not miss it.
Android Studio 2.3 is still in beta, but Android
Finally, if you update your app with this version of the settings update,
You can try it now
Another area where Android developers are suffering is casting
It would be relevant.
From the development environment settings to the actual launch, you can easily
A test environment will be developed to test and improve quality
Easier to set up test framework and unit in Android studio
You will be able to test and test espresso for ui testing
The functionality of the library will be further enhanced.
I have good news.
To test your mouth on various devices in the cloud
The cloud test lab service is scheduled to start
Furthermore, if you launch your app through Google Play,
Automatically test your app on the most widely used devices,
I'll tell you the results
Next, there are libraries that are also very helpful when developing real apps.
It has been released together
Sun is a bit late, but the design support library is open
I use this to design what is commonly used in the design of microclauses
Guidelines can easily be applied to your app
The current version of the design support library is based on the floating
Moving tool bar Snack bar
Includes a 5% text view and much more
Of course, it supports both the latest version as well as Android 2.1 and above.
Various material theme neighbors will be added in the future.
Another thing to keep your fingers healthy for data binding is Live
Was introduced
xml Establish the relationship between the injured ui and the actual app data.
At 2 o'clock, the frequently used Find-view vid at the time of actual coding
You can write a horde in a form that is much simpler and easier to follow without
It's possible
Data binding plugin over Fred's wave, though still in beta
You can use it right away, and in the future,
Buda is going to melt naturally, so please look forward to it.
After last year, the smoke inside gets wider.
Android Why and Android Wear Including New Orange On Mode
Otto tv products have also been updated with new iot
Android platform Blair and some communication protocols have been released
As more details will be released, the developers will
Please listen to new opportunities
Finally, good news for developers interested in Android development
There is
Google has partnered with an online lecture site called Liu Zheng to develop Android
You can study the contents of the first half of Android
If you need feedback and assistance between the ports,
You can check the contents of each river free of charge.
The same
Patterns from Google Korea skyrocketed 2 s
Take advantage of t again so that you can study Android more easily
I will help
Please keep your eyes on the future.
So far, we've briefed developers on Android-related news
For more information about each feature, please see our
Developer site or Korea Core Developer Blog
Please refer to the dg Korea page. Thank you.
U